viviane de vassoigne ancien délégué
d'enfance et partage
accueillis par roger jacqueline bouton
ce sont les grands parents de laura une
petite fille de 5 ans activement
recherché par les gendarmes est caché
par sa famille laura n'a commis aucun
crime
aucun délit mais elle a un jour expliqué
avec ces mots à sa grand mère que son
père a abusé d'elle à l'époque toute la
famille vivait encore en région
parisienne elle avait 16 mois jour en
rentrant de chez son père je ne voulais
pas qu'on la touche et me disait mamie
bobo papa méchant bobo par tam est chaud
et elle faisait voir son petit sexe qui
était rouge à l'intérieur elle serait
dit c'est à vous les plus courts la
touche
et donc j'ai dit elle à dire son pâtit
aussi la même chose et ma fille a donc
été porté plainte elle
la plainte n'a pas eu vraiment de suite
c'est ce qu'on a appris apa très
longtemps mais c'est pas une plante ça
qu'est ce que c'est que ça mais enfin on
a le procès d'emballant pêche et le jaf
a débouté ma fille ça s'est passé en
france pour protéger leurs à sa maman
fui la région parisienne vient se
réfugier en martinique dans cette maison
le père métropolitain porte plainte la
justice exige que l'enfant de 5 ans
retourne dans l'hexagone les gendarmes
sont venus la chercher
ils ont perquisitionné cette maison ne
l'ont pas trouvée la justice doit
entendre ses propos
on doit mettre en oeuvre quelque chose
pour pouvoir la protéger nous voulons
qu'elles soient produites pour des jets
et qu'elle reste avec sa mère et qu'elle
ne soit pas contrainte d'une façon ou
d'une autre de repartir en métropole
elle sera manu militari mise dans un
avion
et elle ira rejoindre son père voilà ce
qu'on veut faire subir à une enfant qui
présente déjà et un syndrome post
traumatique
donc moi je suis je voudrais bien que
magistrat que jusqu au procureur que
quelques me donner
raison de ce transfert les grands
parents de laura nous ont montré son
témoignage est autorisé à le diffuser
[Musique]
mais quoi dans sa bouche pour l'avocat
de la famille bouton les magistrats de
l'hexagone ont très certainement
considérer que la martinique n'était pas
la france et que la mère avait fui à
l'étranger
de plus il estime que les magistrats ne
crois pas l'enfant l'embêtant c'est que
le procureur de la ba a décidé de
classer sans suite
donc a décidé de ne pas croire l'enfant
c'est grâce à mon sens que ce type
d'affaires là ne bénéficient pas de
traitement judiciaire conséquent c'est à
dire avec un enquêteur qui auditionne
l'enfant après avoir reçu une formation
visiblement ça n'a pas été le cas
m germany demande à la justice un
moratoire dans cette affaire le temps
que l'enfant de 5 ans soit de nouveau
entendu par les enquêteurs
quant à laura et sa mère vous ne les
verrez pas elles se cachent des
gendarmes
quelque part en martinique